lo escuchamos jurar Bueno lo vimos en
France 24 curar lealtad a la iglesia
también a la iglesia anglicana a la
iglesia de Escocia es un Rito lleno de
simbolismos religiosos pero es al mismo
tiempo legal Sí yo creo que hay que
destacar ante todo que la ceremonia de
la coronación es una ceremonia de
carácter religioso que envuelve
lógicamente elementos constitucionales
que están
íntimamente ligados a la existencia de
la iglesia protestante de la cual El
Monarca británico es la cabeza O sea que
todo está muy enmarcado en como el Rey
Carlos III es el representante legal de
esa iglesia protestante pero que al
mismo tiempo Y esta es la gran novedad
tiene la misión de proteger y permitir
que otras religiones y que otras
creencias
puedan
existir y proliferar Dentro de este
criterio de Gran diversidad y de Gran
universalidad el Rey Carlos III ha
puesto mucha atención en este tema él
Desde los primeros pasos que se dieron
en la preparación de esta coronación ha
estado
íntimamente vinculado a todos los
detalles y fue particularmente
específico en este tema de la diversidad
de Fresh y de la posibilidad de otras
expresiones